this guy baked himself a cake
and pretended it was from spider-man
and it but you know what yeah i'm glad
he's confirmed for the next film
okay so if you've hit the web recently
you've probably seen that there's a ton
of new spider-man 3
updates and announcements i've been
holding off on fully breaking them down
until we have a bigger picture on how
it's all going to come together
but with the recent rumors about some
returning actors now circulating
i thought i'd take a deep dive into
everything we know about the film
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you don't anything ruined then i
recommend that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
as we're giving away three marvel phase
one box sets
but i'll give you more info on how to
win one of those towards the end of the
video
anyway without the way as always this is
the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
though we don't know what the title of
the upcoming film will be
we do have it confirmed from amy pascal
that the movie
will have a play on home in it now we've
had a lot of things up in the air such
as spider-man home run
homesick spider-man home safe spider-man
no place like home and so on however
i've done a bit of digging and after
discovering that a certain amazon tv
show
is actually made by sony i've come to
the conclusion
that the movie will be called spider-man
homelander
yes that's right you headed here first
and it's pretty much going to be about
homeland they're trying to drink ant
may's breast milk
so make sure that that everyone reports
that as confirmed
because i said it in a video i'm just
kidding but not really
however as of now we don't know what the
name will be but we do know that it will
be released on december 17th
2021 because of the pandemic production
is going to be very tight on this one
and it means that the movie is gonna
have to stop filming pretty much
straight away
the date has been pushed back to likely
allow venom 2 and mobius to have time to
breathe
and if rumors are true they will also
have elements in them that set up this
entry
this was teased at in the mobius trailer
when we saw spider-man easter egg
which hinted at the character being on
the run now sony chairman tony vincera
did state that the movie would only
release if theaters were back up and
running at full capacity
so things are still not 100 confirmed
however the picture house is confident
that we will have some return to
normality by then
and i'm just praying that we don't go
another year without some
mcu releases holland is pretty much
going to be going from the set of
uncharted directly to spider-man 3
but the studio does have confidence that
the movie can hit its 2021 release date
keeping in line with the opening of
venom and mobius who may or may not
feature in the film
in addition to this michael mando also
dropped a little hint
that he could be appearing as scorpion
sooner than you think
however this is still just conjecture at
the moment
what we do know though is that
everyone's birthday wishes have come
true
as jamie foxx will be returning as
electro
in some capacity fox posted some
shocking fan art that teased the
live-action spider-verse
and also hinted that his costume would
not be blue teasing that we might
actually get a more comic book accurate
version of the character
the post was quickly deleted and it is
possibly because mickey got mad that
he'd leaked one of the upcoming
crossovers
which would completely break the
internet but more on that later
now doctor strange has also been
confirmed disappearing in the film
and i think that this teases how elektra
will be entering the movie
looking at the mcu slate going forward
we are firstly getting one division
which is rumored to be in its own pocket
dimension
and the trailers seem to confirm this
doctor strange will reportedly have to
intervene at some
point and the madness that features in
the title of his second film
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness will supposedly be wonder
now you don't have to be tony stark to
figure out that this film will feature
the multiverse
and it is likely that this is how
elektra will be brought across to the
mcu
doctor strange going from one division
to his own film
and then on to spider-man 3 homelander
does tease that the multiverse is going
to be the thread that links not only him
but also the rest of these franchises
together there was a fan theory a while
back which said that strange would be a
great way to make the world forget peter
parker's secret identity
and though this has links to the comics
personally i think that it would cheapen
the ending of the prior movie quite a
quite a lot
end game and time travel sort of lowered
the stakes a bit
as now whenever anything bad happens
such is a big character's death
the heroes would have a way to fix
things by traveling to an alternate
dimension
in my opinion using strange's magic to
alter public perception
would also be something that kind of
breaks the universe as
pretty much everything can be fixed with
the wave of his finger
so i hope that they stay with the
identity reveal as
i'm not a big fan of back pedaling when
things are out in the open
as i think that it cheapens the tension
when revisiting the prior films
it's also been theorized that strange
will be taking up the mental role that's
missing in peter's life
but again i hope this isn't the case as
far from home was really about the
character becoming his own man
after the betrayal by mysterio and the
film's climax in which he ended up
standing on his own two feet
i feel like this would be marvel showing
that they don't really trust the spider
to be the man
and i really hope that he pops up as an
ally rather than someone guiding pierre
through everything
now in addition to these two comic book
characters we do know that zendaya will
be returning his mj
which yeah kind of obvious and that tony
revolori will be back as flash thompson
as we know from the first two films he
hates peter parker but loves spider-man
and i think that it's going to be
interesting to see how he handles
knowing the truth about him
as for marisa tomei john watts the
film's director discussed her role in
the movie
and stated that he sees her as filling
her community organizer role
and that the film will expand on this
even further alongside her relationship
with happy hogan
jk simmons stated that after far from
home he'd also signed on to do two more
sequels
so expect to see him pop up in this film
and probably one of the spin-offs
like venom and mobius unfortunately
charlie cox has ruled out appearing in
the film
and now marvel now have the rights to
daredevil he has stated on the record
that he won't be appearing as pierre's
lawyer
now though we don't know who the villain
is pretty much every interview with both
holland and watts
has had craven the hunter brought up i
think that this would be
absolutely amazing craven is obviously a
bounty hunter
and with peter parker being on the run
for the murder of mysterio and attack on
london
it does make sense to have him brought
in this way the weird rumors that he was
going to be getting a solo craven movie
similar to venom however as of now these
are unsubstantiated
i actually think that mysterio will be
revealed to be alive in the film
and that this is how parker's name will
be cleared he is of course the master of
illusions
i don't know something about his death
and then the way that the parker reveal
was put across
it just gave me the feeling that that
wasn't the last that we saw of him
john cena also posted an image of cerman
on his instagram page
however this shouldn't really be taken
with any weight as
the actor does a lot of cryptic posts
like this and with the recently
announced peacemaker hbo max series
it's difficult to imagine him playing
two comic book characters at the same
time
i know that's never out of the question
as in the case of josh brolin
but yeah it does seem unlikely now on to
the more rumor parts of the video
and over the last couple of weeks we've
had an absolute ton of them
you might have seen headlines like dane
dehorn and kirsten dunster returning
and yeah everything's just all over the
place at the moment
however all of these seem to center
around the idea that we will be getting
a live-action spider-verse
which will pretty much bring old
characters back to the forefront for one
last film
now you may have seen yesterday that
popcorn planet confirmed that both toby
maguire
and andrew garfield will be returning as
their respective spider-man in the mcu
now though signor says he can officially
confirm it
we haven't had it confirmed officially
yet so take it with a pinch of salt for
the moment
however i think that it is very very
likely that these talks
have indeed gone on and if contracts
haven't been signed yet
then they will be at some point in the
future according to signor the deal is
already
done and actually happened before the
pandemic sony are meant to be furious
about it leaking
and they wanted it to be a big reveal at
some point he stated that tom holland's
peter parker
will be facing off against multiple
villains and that this is when maguire
and garfield will come in end game style
to help defeat them all signal also
stated that the 2000 version of green
goblin
would be featuring in the film as well
as multiple spidey fan favorites
like i said take this with it and say it
with me
pinch of salt and uh shout out to the
person who who sent me a picture of some
zoomed in salt
as i'm not sure if there's just too much
going on in this movie at this point
let's face it this mcgarfield team up
deserves a standalone movie
and i'm not sure that spider-man 3 will
have the room to truly do it the justice
that it deserves
with everything that's already happening
in it personally i would love to see
them appear in some form before we get a
full film with the trio
but yeah we're just gonna see how it
plays out now in addition to this
according to mcu cosmic miles morales
will be appearing at some point in the
mcu
the site states that the actor who's
playing him has already been cast
and that he will be appearing in the
future i actually think this makes a lot
of sense as holland's spider-man is sort
of coming to the end of his arc
and though i don't think that that tom
holland will be stepping away anytime
soon sony likely want to line up the
next person to take over the mantle and
i do think that this seems legit
let's face it when the studio is
prepared to make a madame web movie
they're probably also thinking of doing
a mile swan and
after the success of into the
spider-verse i definitely think that
fans will be hyped
we've of course already seen donald
glover as aaron davis in spider-man
homecoming
and he did state that he had a nephew so
yeah all the pieces are in place
anyway that's pretty much everything we
know and
all the major rumors making the rounds
i'd obviously love to hear your thoughts
on them so make sure you comment below
and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our theories and predictions for
season three of the boys which will be
linked after this
as mentioned earlier we're also giving
away three copies of the marvel phase
one box set
and all you have to do to be with the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the win is going to be chosen at random
on the 30th of october so make sure you
get involved
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also become chapters on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care
[Music]
peace
[Music]
so